what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so you know guys the last couple
of months you know I've kind of had an
epiphany
that men are better at everything and I
didn't really like want to come to this
conclusion okay and the reason I came to
this conclusion was because I found out
that women are more likely to kill
infants and the elderly and once I
realized this I I started thinking about
it and I was like I have never heard of
a man baby killer
I have only heard of women baby killers
and it's so interesting because in this
Society it's like we we label women as
these like comforting you know just
innocent creatures and yet I keep seeing
story after story after Story of women
in the news killing children so this
last story actually happened in London
so as you guys know I'm an American but
I do live in London so Lucy leppy is due
to be sentenced later after being found
guilty of murdering seven babies making
her the UK's most prolific child killer
in modern times the 33 year old was also
convicted of trying to kill six other
infants at the Countess of Chester
Hospital the trial lasted more than 10
months and is believed to be the longest
murder trial in the UK Lucy leppy
um was an average nurse who turned into
a baby killer clutching a fluffy purple
comforter out of sight of the jury the
nurse dissolved into tears at reminders
of her home life the 33 year old wept
any mention of her cat's tiger and
smudge and sobbed when the court saw a
photograph of her childlike bedroom with
four fluffy toys laid across her sweet
dreams duvet fairy lights on her bed
frame and art saying leaves Sparkles
wherever you go pinned to the wall her
tears at these points were in sharp
contrast to her expressionless impassive
demeanor when the details of her alleged
crimes were presented to the jury after
the guilty verdicts let beat ranks one
of the most persistent child killers in
modern British history and one of the
most notorious female murderers of the
last century the description by the
prosecutors Nicholas Johnson of letby as
a cold calculated cruel and Relentless
killer was almost word for word the
phrase used by the judge who sentenced
Myra Henley for the Moore's murders more
than 50 years ago it was said of Henley
and Rose West that what made their
crimes more shocking was that these
women were so ordinary letby was the
epitome of ordinary she appeared
conventional in every single way no
complaints have been previously raised
about let beat to the nursing and
midwife Council she was once chosen as
the face of the fundraising campaign by
the Countess of Chester Hospital and
appeared on a poster she's featured in
the Chester standard several times as
part of the newspaper's support for the
baby grown appeal aimed at raising 3
million to build a new unit at the
hospital in 2012 she appeared in a photo
holding a baby as a part of a story on a
person who had donated money to to the
appeal and in 2013 she was the subject
of a short interview about her job where
she told the newspaper I hope the new
unit will provide a greater degree of
privacy and space for parents and
siblings letby seemed particularly close
to her father documents seen by the
guardian show he forcefully defended her
when Executives at the Countess of
Chester Hospital removed her from the
neonatal unit in July 2016 after the
death of two triplet boys John leppy was
convinced of his daughter's innocence
and received the backing of Tony
Chambers the hospital's chief executive
who decided that lepi should be allowed
to return to the unit in January 2017
when pediatric consultants angrily
complained about his decisions leppy's
father threatened to refer them to the
general medicine Council they were
forced to write a letter of apology but
maintained she should not be allowed to
return to the unit and guys you know
what's crazy I'm reading this but
if this was a guy
that would never happen
if this was a guy that had gone through
all of these steps that had this many
complaints that they had this many kids
die around him I promise you he would
not be given the same benefit of the
doubt but because we have this Society
where we really label women as innocent
and like like they're not capable of
committing these types of crimes
um I really think we have a lot of adult
children women hanging around where they
really don't see any real consequence
for these types of decisions so
she was arrested a little more than a
year later on July 4th 2018 and her
father was there to witness it it was 6
a.m on a clear blue July Morning When
letby opened the door to a
police detective her instinctual smile
dropped when the officer introduced
himself leppy was let out of her Chester
home in handcuffs 11 minutes later later
looking Ash and face dressed in her
nightie and a blue Lee copper tracksuit
she told the female officer she had just
had a knee surgery and she was placed in
the back of an unmarked police car her
family had returned from a holiday in
Turkey the day before and John leppy had
stayed the night in court she sniffed
away tears and she said her father had
made her bed after the arrest it also
came out in the trial that letby had an
affair with one of the senior doctors at
the hospital letby perhaps looked the
most uncomfortable when she was being
asked about a senior doctor whom the
prosecutor suggested she was having an
affair she collapsed in tears halfway
through the trial when the married
Doctor Who Can't Be Named came into the
court to give evidence for the
prosecution letby told the jurors he had
been her best friend although she had
not worked with him for long his name
was written in on scroll the notes
recovered from leppy's bedroom alongside
lyrics to A Craig David's song that that
read love was all we needed but time let
us down the pair regularly exchanged
Facebook messages went for meals and
walks and visited her home the nature of
their relationship was said to be
significant he was one of the doctors
who would be called when babies suddenly
deteriorated she harmed them it was
suggested during the trial to get his
personal attention the weakness of
lepy's defense was exposed when she
failed to produce any medical expert
colleague family member or friend to
testify on her behalf the only witness
called by her legal team was a hospital
plumber who looked bewildered by his
presence in court as those watching on
um so there you have it guys one of the
most prolific serial killers in London
was a woman and the thing is my question
is would she have been given this many
chances had she not been a woman and to
me it is actually absolutely insane that
this chick was killing children to get
the attention of a doctor she was having
an affair with potentially
you know
and I I think we're gonna keep seeing
cases like this until the justice system
starts Prosecuting women for crimes
because the the truth of the matter is a
lot of women
you know um kill their own children and
get off there were multiple cases last
year where we found grown adult women
throwing infants in a dumpster and
getting out of it and I really think
we're in a society where women are not
held accountable for their actions and
until we start holding women
to the same criminal standards that we
hold men to we're going to keep seeing
women taking advantage of that power for
whatever reason women are extremely
malicious
um when it when we're given power I
don't know why I don't know what it is
but it just seems to be a trend across
the board
um and now we have one of the most
prolific baby killers in London being
put in prison so it's just in that Lucy
letby has been given a life sentence in
jail for the murder of seven babies
as you guys know last week I I covered
Logan Paul's beef with Dylan danis now
Logan and Dylan have a fight scheduled
on October 15th essentially a couple of
years ago Logan and his brother Jake had
a beef with Dylan and they ended up
sleeping with Dylan's ex-girlfriend now
Dylan did not
he did not forget this he this man was
like you know what I remember this
clearly so Dylan decides to tweet over a
hundred pictures of Logan's new fiance
with other men
now guys I just I've been on Twitter all
week I just kept wondering when will it
end every day I would pull up my Twitter
I'd be tweeting and I would just see
another picture of her with another
famous guy like from Bow Wow to
um Shark Boy you remember Sharkboy and
Lava Girl You Know shark boy she was
with then I think there was a picture of
her with maybe Shaq or something and
then um
you know Leonardo DiCaprio got in there
and I was just like guys this cannon
this can't get worse
Dylan until Dylan tweeted yesterday he
said if I dropped this picture it would
end the fight end his engagement and I
might even find myself in jail
I'm I'm baffled like what what is this
picture I don't I I just can't imagine
like what is it a sex tape because at
this point there's already been like a
hundred dudes like I I genuinely think
there's a picture of a hundred guys so
my question is what is what is worse
than this so Andrew tweets back at him I
was trying very hard not to get involved
in this and I'm still trying to stay out
of this but I open my Twitter inbox and
had a message from Dylan and he's really
not lying I actually think this is good
because I think we're gonna have a
general conversation in society about
women with promiscuous past because okay
Logan's may have been public but we all
know that there are many men with wives
out there that have crazy past that
people don't know about and you know I I
I was thinking about this the other day
and I was thinking about how men have so
much to lose in marriage like they have
everything to lose and these days
there's really not much to gain you know
we saw in the last video that there's a
50 divorce rate and if we assume half of
the men are unhappy in marriage you know
of them that stay married right and I
think that's a honestly
a generous number if I'm gonna be honest
um or they stay together for the kids or
whatever
it's really a 75 failure rate and I was
thinking about this and I'm like well if
you marry a hoe if a girl has over five
Partners she only has a 20 chance of a
happy marriage so knowing this
information I really think of men locked
down the marriage market like if
Leonardo DiCaprio the top guys got
together and said we are only marrying
virgins no other woman is qualified for
marriage I really think younger women
would adapt
um but the problem is we keep seeing
examples of women where it really works
out for you know um call her the chick
from caller daddy ended up getting
married or she's about to get married
you know we keep seeing men wife up hoes
you know even though that's the
exception it's not the rule you know the
media is going to spin it as if it is
the rule and so now we have Logan's uh
fiance who spent her 20s with every dude
in Hollywood and now is going to come
out at the finish line with a winner and
I think I think it just it really is
gonna red pill a lot of guys because she
did you know wait to have sex with him
and I think a lot of guys think that's
like a sign of Purity and you know
sometimes it's just a sign of a
predatory woman that's really just
learned the game
um not that I really have any real
answers for you guys I'm not I'm not the
queen of like pick up and telling you
all that stuff but my my I think of
things in like a general Society point
of view and I really think of men locked
down the marriage market and said you
know what
we're only doing virgins any everyone
else is just for fun and in five years
you know maybe the next round of like 21
22 year olds will wait
and adapt I think that's really because
women don't really care what the average
guy wants unfortunately I think you guys
have seen clip after clip after clip of
me on my show and with woman after woman
after woman showing she does not care
what the average man wants so knowing
this information it's really there's
only going to be change when the top men
adapt to this sort of thing so you know
Andrew Tate comes in and actually it
looks like we're gonna get an Andrew
Tate and Dylan collab
and he said if you come to Romania we
can Spar no problem G Dylan says I have
massive respect for top G and his skill
set it would be awesome to get in some
rounds with the Cobra depending on a
scheduling but this is a huge
possibility and you know I would
actually love to have a really open
conversation and I know this will never
happen because they'll probably beat
each other up but I I think it would be
good to have an open conversation with
the guys about body count because you
know
I'm pretty sure Dylan had an issue
dating promiscuous woman a promiscuous
woman I I'm sure Tate has at some point
like I don't think any man is immune to
having fallen in love with a hoe like I
think this is a pretty common Trope you
know beauty is powerful and as I've said
you know the women that men are
accepting as wives a hundred years ago
would have been thrown away it would
have been thrown out they would not have
been accepted so you know I've said this
before and I'll say it again most women
are very lucky to be alive in this time
period because a hundred years ago I
swear to God nobody would take us they'd
be like nope next next and so you know I
I just think we should have a general
conversation with the men that women
want to be with about what they actually
want because the issue we have is the
media is lying to us marketing is lying
to us and women were so susceptible to
propaganda you know I can't think of one
girl in the media in the mainstream
media that has traditional no wife
qualities even the more like I guess
America's sweetheart kind ones seem to
have the same outcomes like I think of
Taylor Swift I think of Selena Gomez
they were really America's sweetheart
and yet they still are by themselves so
it tells us we we have a media and
marketing and really all the big
influencers don't want men and women to
be together and I think it goes back to
the egalitarian principle where men and
women were told men and women are equal
and in my opinion we're just not so
speaking of Taylor Swift our next story
is about
women's inherent nature to never be
happy now guys I don't
I don't want you to misconstrue this I
don't say this to hate on women but I
think as women it's helpful to know how
we're just like naturally wired to be
and I don't I I genuinely don't know
what it is but I really think it's since
Adam and Eve right Eve was in the garden
with Adam and they had everything life
was perfect and then the serpent got
into Eve's ear and said no this isn't
good enough eat the apple eat the apple
and then Eve convinced Adam to eat the
apple and I really think the greatest
sin of man was listening to women
because I really think women are a weak
spot in the family unit because we are
so susceptible to propaganda
and we want to be cool we want to adapt
to the group I don't I don't say this
like I'm happy about it
but I just think when we start to look
at Trends in society we start to look at
how women are wired the things that we
do
it just doesn't seem like anything makes
us happy
um it seems like we're almost happy when
there's problems I can't explain it I
don't understand why but you know Taylor
Swift is a world-renowned superstar
you know she is so rich this girl's like
I don't know I think I just saw she gave
over a hundred K to each trucker that
was on her tour something like that and
you know genuinely I don't think Taylor
is a bad person but I do think she has
been infected with this mindset where
she paints herself as a victim in every
relationship that she's in and
unfortunately you know for the last
decade nobody's told her the truth and
unfortunately you can see how Society
has almost been going through the same
thing and most women have been going to
through the same thing because of how
powerful and influential Taylor is like
you don't become a world-renowned
superstar without having some people
relate to your music and in every album
that she writes you know she's the
victim
um and you can just see this like
Trope of of Taylor Swift it's so funny
because if you look at her earlier stuff
she's like this sweet girl she's not
really political and then you know money
and fame and attention
she gets all of it and you can just see
her becoming more and more feminist over
time having more and more failed
relationships over time
um to the point where her last
relationship it's rumored that it ended
because he really wanted to settle down
and she really wanted to go on tour and
there's nothing wrong with either of
those things but it goes to show that
women can have everything and still
never be happy you know she's at the
point where you know I think she's 33
she doesn't have much time left if she
wants to have children
um and yet She'll always pick her career
over a family and I genuinely have no
problem with women picking what they
want to pick I think a lot of people
misconstrue my opinions because I I
don't have a problem with women choosing
things what I have a problem with is the
whining later and we just have this
tendency so Taylor Swift is going to
talk about a business deal that she did
when she was 18 maybe 16 I don't know
younger where she signed her music away
her music rights away and what happened
with those rights let's pull the clip
after I was denied the chance to
purchase my music outright my entire
catalog was sold to scooter bronze
Ithaca Holdings in a deal that I'm told
was funded by the Soros family 23
capital and the Carlisle Group
yet to this day
none of these investors
have ever bothered to contact me or my
team directly
to perform their due diligence on their
investment
on their investment in me
to ask how I might feel about the new
owner of my art
the music I wrote the videos videos I
created
photos of me my handwriting
my album designs
and of course scooter never contacted me
or my team to discuss it prior to the
sale or even when it was announced
I'm fairly certain he knew exactly how
it would feel about it though
and let me just say that the definition
of the toxic male privilege in our
industry is people saying but he's
always been nice to me when I'm raising
valid concerns about artists and their
rights to own their music
and of course he's nice to you if you're
in this room you have something he needs
the fact is that private Equity is what
enabled this man to think according to
his own social media post
that he could buy me
good I'm obviously not going willingly
yet the most amazing thing was to
discover that it would be the women in
our industry who would have my back
and show me the most vocal support at
one of the most difficult times and I
will never ever forget it like
ever so let me get this straight like
this is my issue
you know
women if you're going to go into a man's
world then take what comes with it
you're telling me that you are entitled
for another guy who owns the rights to
your music to ask you how you feel about
it
and this is why we don't get taken
seriously like I can't even I can't even
blame the guys for not taking us
seriously because you know she she goes
into a man's world and then whines when
it's Cutthroat that's what a man's world
is it's not it's it's a Cutthroat world
it's always competitive and nobody has
to ask you how you freaking feel about
it all right this woman is worth
780 million and she is still whining
wine and I just cannot stand it and did
you hear that he's always been nice to
me is the toxic masculine
what did she say the toxic masculine
trait
uh
I I would say that about a woman too
and and this is the thing like
I have no problem with women wanting to
go into media and entertainment uh look
look at look at me look at me I'm here
but what I what I do have an issue with
as women going into these industries and
complaining later saying everyone wants
to sleep with you saying everybody's out
to get you when honestly
half of these chicks flirt first and two
half of the time
these women are just whining they're not
giving special treatment because they're
so used to the pretty privilege
um that they've gotten their whole life
and I'm sorry when it comes down to
money and dollars
um and I'm sorry when it comes down to
money in dollars men don't care they're
here to make money they're not here to
ask you how you feel about things and
the more women that do this the more I
just say ban them you know sometimes I
have policy prescriptions
that wouldn't necessarily benefit me
personally I think about this sometimes
but it's like if women and I think about
this with sports with women's sports
it's like you give women a league you
give women more pay and what do they do
wine complain blame the patriarchy and I
just say if you guys are Gonna Keep
whining if you're going to keep bitching
if you're going to keep moaning get out
of here and she also said something
peculiar as well where she said all of
the women in the industry supported me
and you'll see this like innate Instinct
of women to protect other women at all
costs it just baffles me because even
when women are saying absolutely asinine
stupid things it's like we still protect
them and I don't understand why
okay so the next story was I was
scrolling through you guys know I get so
many stories from Twitter right and I
was I was scrolling through Twitter the
other day and I saw the average cost of
wedding by state and I really wanted to
point out how it's interesting how the
cost of weddings go up more and more but
the length of marriages go down more and
more and it's so interesting because
it's like the less value Brides bring
like we've talked about this we don't
bring Purity anymore we don't bring
youth most women are not taught to be
submissive so it's like what what do
brides really bring nowadays not much
unfortunately guys I don't say this with
like a happy heart you know I just we
got to be honest with ourselves so the
less and less Brides bring to the table
um it seems like the cost of weddings go
up and up and there's actually been
studies that have come out saying that
the more the wedding costs the less
likely it is to last and the funny thing
is how Hollywood you know every Media
company ever has just sold that you're
supposed to have this one perfect day
that I think women think more about the
wedding and less about the marriage
and it's so funny it just seems like
women just want a wedding for Instagram
without a like you can go to the
courthouse and get married for like 50
bucks yeah let's go through the average
cost by state so
I'm from Chicago so we'll start there
average cost of wedding in the USA by
state so
Illinois 37
000 dollars
okay California almost 100K 77
000 on a wedding New York 46
000 and guys the way my mind works you
could just go to a courthouse get
married for 50 bucks
that's like a down payment on a house
you could go on a whole you could like
tour Europe
with that money but it really shows like
the values we have in society where it's
like we don't care about the marriage we
care about the wedding and you'll you'll
see stories of like previous generations
like one two three generations ago were
they they knew each other for three
months and they got married but it's
like we keep raising the price for men
on commitment you know guy guys used to
date a chick for three months and get
married can can you imagine a man doing
that nowadays like can you can you
imagine that that sounds unheard of so
now it's like okay he's got the risk of
losing half his stuff all right he's got
the risk of losing his children he's got
the risk of getting falsely accused of a
crime he's got the risk of
finding out later that his wife has
slept with a million people
and
now he has the cost of spending in some
states up to a hundred thousand dollars
I want to see what is the cheapest state
and it looks like the cheapest state is
Wyoming it would be really interesting
to see if Wyoming had longer marriage
rates than other states and if the high
I'd imagine since they've said the more
people spend on weddings the less their
marriage lasts but it'd just be
interesting to see if Wyoming had a
super low divorce rate
but these are the trends I see in
society it's becoming more materialistic
and it's so funny because I hear women
say again and again and again they can't
afford children yet they find a way to
afford a 50 000 wedding a twenty
thousand dollar wedding and it's
becoming even though marriage really is
a way for people to trans to basically
have generational wealth right if people
get married and stay married that's a
way to have generational wealth but it's
so interesting because I was thinking
about how in society we really have a
society where men are slaving away for
women because what happens is men pay
over a hundred thousand dollars more in
tax in their lifetime than women so men
are essentially working their lives to
give money to women and you know I don't
think in history that's always been a
bad thing because typically in exchange
for this they would get Purity they
would get you they would get kids you
know 200 years ago each woman had seven
children
yet in modern times I don't even think
we have three kids
you know we're not even
having enough kids to replace the
parents and then a third a third child
and
you know we're getting married around I
I think it's in some countries it's
literally at 35 like I was in Ireland
last year and I think 34 35 was the
average marriage date
and this is the guys this is the society
we're in so
you know and and I realized too that I
think we have a society of basically
Kings and lonely men because most
of the women are sleeping with the top
ten twenty percent of men and the bottom
80 percent of men are just lonely and
it's really interesting because the
average men are the ones running Society
the 45 55 60 000
a year jobs you know the bus drivers the
plumbers the electricians the
construction workers a lot of average
salaried men the coal miners
um really run Society but yet what what
do they get in return these days for
running Society they used to get a wife
and kids but we keep seeing the number
of sexless men just rising and rising
and then you see the number of men
addicted to porn rising and Rising
um and even if they do get married you
know a lot of wives don't choose to stay
so one example of again the common trend
of women never being happy
is Larissa Pippen you know Larissa
Pippen was married to a superstar she
had her
bills taking care of the rest of her
life yet what what did she do she
decided to divorce her husband she
decided to post super provocative
pictures on Instagram and now she's
dating a guy 17 years younger than her
that was friends with her son so Michael
Jordan's son Marcus Jordan reveals that
him and Larissa Pippin are now planning
their wedding so guys look at the woman
on the left she's got these claw
fingernails she's in a bikini right
um no shirt on
uh clearly a bunch of Botox plastic
surgery you know the these women it's so
funny because you can't even tell the
difference between wives
and mothers
and single women they look exactly the
same and this is a woman that was
married to the top what one percent of
men and I think that's really
frustrating to the average guy because
it's like if these women can't be happy
married to the top 10 20 of men you know
what will make them happy and then I
also see a common trend of like the men
saying well just find a good woman and I
really think the new standard again for
a wife really should be a virgin if
there's an 80 chance of a happy marriage
if the chick's a virgin I really think
men should hold out and start demanding
virgins but it's really only going to
happen if the top men you know do it and
we do see a trend of men walking away
from Marriage I mean
but however there are predatory women
that go after younger men and you're
going to keep seeing this trend and and
you really you see this trend of older
women going after younger guys that
really haven't been through the ringer
yet and don't know better so we're gonna
see some of the comments let's see how
Twitter's reacting to this she was 17
when he was born
they got yeah like this is this is crazy
and it's so funny because women will big
up other women that date younger but
when a guy dates younger he's predatory
he just wants uh
um he's manipulative when really guys
you know when when men date younger they
typically want to take care of the chick
where when women take young date younger
they still divorce his ass that's a
crazy thing in order to go over our last
story of the day I want to talk about
you know a realization that I had the
last couple months was that men are
smarter and better at everything now I
know this sounds crazy to you guys
you're like Pearl you're just you're
just a woman hater well
I had this realization when
I thought to myself huh
the only time women seem to make a lot
of money is in media and that's
monetizing Beauty
on some level
we don't have female Elon musks we don't
have female
um
we don't have female Albert Einsteins
like if women are really that smart
wouldn't we see the results in the world
and I really think they just make up
these tests I swear to God I think they
they make these IQ tests more
catered to women so we think we're
smarter than we are because I really
think the more you you big up the EGO of
women uh the more men women don't want
to be with men that are on their level
and I just think there's some campaign
to make women feel like we're so special
and so important even though most of us
are just average chicks that aren't that
special or aren't that important and
it's so funny because whenever I bring
this up whenever I say to the chicks
guys we're not that special we're not
that smart and we're pretty average like
if you say that to a guy it's so funny
because we've spent a generation telling
men they're idiots like we'll just say
oh he's a guy he's dumb and it's so
funny because the guys just kind of take
it they just say okay but if you tell a
women women if you tell women we're
idiots when we're dumb and we're just
average and men are smarter it's like
this visceral reaction it's like ah ah
my life is so hard so
trans women biological males have been
banned from competing in women's chess
competitions so you know this is again
we see the IQ tests where it says that
men are on one end or the other end of
the IQ distribution and women are all
gathered in the middle and you know I
hear you maybe there's some truth to
that but you know I just don't believe
it sorry and and this is the this is the
thing like we can look at what the the
institutions are telling us and what the
media is telling us or I can look at
what's in front of my eyes
and I'm sorry but as women we just lead
we make decisions emotionally what do
you think guys if we were so smart the
most important decision of our life
which is picking a husband don't you
think we'd be smart about picking one
like seriously like don't you don't
think we would be smart and think to
ourselves let me pick a good husband
instead of making a baby with a drug
dealer
or a guy that's cheated on every single
girlfriend he's ever had or a guy that's
super famous
oh no oh no that's not what we do and
I'm not trying to be rude but I just
gotta look
at what we pick so now this has
transitioned into chess tournaments so
again you know there's no
physical
strength needed in chess tournaments but
women are smarter than men right and the
average women are smarter than the
average men yet biological males have
been banned from competing in women's
chess competitions if we're so smart why
don't we just dominate why don't we just
kill it like we just kill everything
right we're just so we're so um
smart so the comments say bro why is
there even a woman in a men's
competition in the first place
Opus says because men are more
intelligent that's not even a
competition a three-year-old infant can
beat a woman Grand Master and you know I
was actually thinking about when I was a
kid and I I have a I have a younger
brother and we used to fight when I was
younger because I just didn't want to
listen to him
and then the older I got the more I
started to realize I'm like oh dang it
my little brother's smarter than me and
I really think once as women we just
have this realization guys I think it
helps us when we start to realize hey
women in general were never happy then
we can at least adapt and when we're
feeling like maybe I should leave my
marriage my children and everything I've
built because I saw a soap opera the
other day maybe we'll be like you know
what women were never happy so let's try
to be happy or when we think well I'm
smarter than my husband so I should be
in control
maybe we'll step back and think well
maybe he's smarter okay and I'm not even
trying to be rude guys but we just have
monetized Beauty so much and I'll even
use myself as an example I'll admit this
like you're in an advantage as a chick
like you just get more eyeballs like
more more people want to listen to you
when you're a girl a guy has to work 10
times as hard to get in the same
position as we do in media
um and I and I think we get into more
trouble when we start to just think it's
all by herself and we don't have any
advantage and you know
um it's not easier in life being a chick
I think it's easier when you know that
it is
um so Kappa says now they just need to
do this for all sports so again this is
what we're feeding into the delusion
that men and women are equal and again I
think there's a natural hierarchy in the
world guys God men women children and I
think the more we tell us women that
we're equal and that we're just as good
and just as powerful and and more
deserving than men I think that's when
evil really happens because
unfortunately when women get power as we
saw with the baby killer um a lot of us
when we're not led by the guidance of a
man we just aren't the best people and I
don't know what it is
um
you know
call me crazy but I don't know guys let
me know what you think in the comments
and let me know what do you think is the
appropriate amount to spend on a wedding
and what are your solutions for you know
prescriptions in this crazy you know
crazy world we're in let me know in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time